Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass Ligatour, Ausgabe Nummer 3. Wir wollen sprechen über die Premier League, La Liga, die Ligue 1 und die Serie A. Hier in Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 184. Und ich freue mich sehr, eine große Runde begrüßen zu dürfen, inklusive eines Neuzugangs. Den heben wir uns natürlich zum Schluss auf. Ich begrüße zu meiner Linken, er ist in die Rasenfunk Headquarters gekommen. Christian Bernhardt, hallo Christian.
Hallo Max, hallo in die Runde.
Ich begrüße zugeschaltet Nils Kärn, hallo Nils. Sehr gut und ebenfalls hier, how are you? Jogi Hebel für die Premier League. Das war cringe, hallo Jogi. Ja, ja, ja, genau. Sagt der, der Jürgen Klopp interviewt. Gut, wobei das ging natürlich, das war ein schlechtes Beispiel. Der Max ist schon auf Hochtouren, wie gut, das passt ja auch wunderbar jetzt dann zu einem neuen Gast, den wir haben. Dem zeige ich mich dann gleich von meiner besten Seite. Ich freue mich sehr, dass Alexis Menuge hier ist. Ihr kennt ihn natürlich aus dem Sportradio 360, vielleicht auch von der Saunen. Hallo, Alexis. Ja, sehr schön, dass wir dich hier für den Rasenfunk gewinnen konnten. Wir haben uns ein bisschen Gedanken über dieses Format gemacht, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, und wir werden das in Zukunft so machen, die Reihenfolge der Ligen, über die wir sprechen, ist nicht von vorher klar, sondern ich gebe den Imperator. Und jeder muss jetzt ein Plädoyer halten, mit welcher Liga wir anfangen. Nils, du darfst mal vorlegen, warum war das, was in der La Liga passiert ist, in der spanischen Liga das Wichtigste?
Ah, da tue ich mich jetzt schwer, weil mein Plädoyer fällt eher negativ aus. Ich würde eher erklären, warum La Liga aktuell die langweiligste Liga Europas oder der Top-Liga zumindest ist. Dort fallen die wenigsten Tore. Es ist die Liga mit den ältesten Spielern. Man hat ja auch in der Champions League gesehen, dass da noch nicht so viele Siege von Spanien gefallen sind. Erst zwei. Also mein Plädoyer über La Liga würde heute eher interessant sein, weil es negativ wäre.
Okay, gut.
Das ist ein interessanter Ansatz. Wir hören uns dann am Ende dieses Segments.
Also ich glaube, wenn ich so über meine Liga sprechen würde, dann würde mich mein Sender kicken, glaube ich. Deswegen habe ich schon gewonnen. Ich glaube, es ist easy money. Newcastle, glaube ich, haben wir zu besprechen. Die großen Teams haben wir zu besprechen, die allesamt gepunktet haben. United, die das eben nicht getan haben. Also wir haben doch, glaube ich, eine Menge Ansätze, die man da irgendwie verfolgen könnte.
Sehr schön. Christian Bernhard, was, warum die Serie A?
Also ich werfe jetzt einfach mal in den Raum. Die Mannschaft der Stunde Europas. Napoli, acht Spiele, acht Siege. Das lasse ich einfach mal so stehen.
Und der FC Turin hat beim Auswärtsspiel in Neapel Mozzarella mitgebracht, wieder säckeweise nach Hause habe ich gesehen auf Social Media.
So kann man auch noch was Positives rausziehen, wenn man ohne Punkte nach Hause fährt.
Gut, Alexi, was hat es mit der Ligue 1-Aussicht? Was ist da so alles passiert?
An diesem Wochenende insbesondere ein Deutscher, der heftig kritisiert wurde, warum geht er zur Olympique Lyon als Weltmeister und Tralala. Und der hat ein Riesenspiel bestritten und nicht gegen eine kleine Mannschaft, nämlich gegen die AS Monaco mit Niko Kovac, Kevin Volland und der großartige Alex Nübel. Und der hat auf jeden Fall eine weltklasse Leistung abgeliefert und wird endlich mal in der französischen Presse schön gefeiert.
Oh, das ist jetzt... Bis auf Nies habt ihr es mir nicht einfach gemacht. Ich würde sagen, wenn jemand vorlegt, vielleicht bin ich da jetzt gebeißt, aber wenn jemand sagt, da spielt die beste Mannschaft Europas, dann müssen wir mit der Serie A beginnen. Dieses Plädoyer wird aber jetzt kritisch hinterfragt werden von allen anderen Dreien. Das ist ja hoffentlich klark.
Ja, völlig richtig. Und ich möchte aber auch nicht mir die Zitate im Mund umdrehen lassen. Denn ich habe nicht gesagt, die beste Mannschaft Europas, sondern nur die mit Abstand ligamäßig erfolgreichste. Denn 8 aus 8 kann halt im Moment niemand vorweisen.
8 Siege aus 8 Spielen, das ist tatsächlich beeindruckend. Erst 3 Gegentore für Napoli. Was, außer der heimische Mozzarella, was macht Napoli so stark?
Das Spiel jetzt am Wochenende war ein ganz gutes Beispiel dafür. Der FC Turin war zu Gast, ganz interessant mit einem neuen Trainer, Ivan Juric. Ivan Juric ist der Trainer, der letztes Jahr noch auf der Bank von Hellas Verona saß. Der letzte Spieltag nach Neapel kam. Napoli hätte nur das letzte Spiel gewinnen müssen, um sich für die Champions League zu qualifizieren. Doch Ivan Juric und Hellas Verona haben Napoli gestoppt. Und Juwe ist dadurch noch in die Champions League reingerutscht als Vierter. Also eigentlich hat es sozusagen Napoli auf der Ziellinie selbst in der Hand und ist nicht vollendet. Und dementsprechend war jetzt die Rückkehr von Juric logischerweise ein bisschen emotional begleitet. Und Torino hat es wieder sehr gut gemacht, hat wie gegen Juwe auch sehr gut miterhalten. Juric hat da sehr guten neuen Floh reingebracht. Und Napoli hatte einige Rückschläge, hat wieder einen Elfmeter verschossen in Sinje beim 0-0, schon der dritte in der Saison. Aber Napoli findet im Moment wirklich in jedem Spiel irgendwie Wege, das Ding doch noch zu gewinnen. Diesmal war es ein spätes Tor von Ossie Mann, der herausragend im Moment in Form ist. Der ist wirklich Naturgewalt da vorne drin. Kann jedem nur raten, sich vielleicht das Tor anzusehen. Das 1-0, da steht er gefühlt 2,5 Meter in der Luft. Nicht nur gefühlt, ich glaube, würde nachgerechnet 2,52 Meter. Und wie gesagt, Napoli ist wirklich beeindruckend. Du hast es angesprochen, logisch steht nur 3 Gegentore. Das sind logisch eine Basis, auf die man so etwas aufbauen kann. Also Luciano Spalletti, der neue Trainer, hat da absolut defensive Stabilität reingebracht. Aber das Schöne ist, Napoli hat sich auch die vielen schönen spielerischen Elemente, die sie Gott sei Dank seit Jahren schon haben, angefangen unter Sarri, beibehalten. Und im Moment, wie gesagt, sie sind kaum zu überwinden, haben vorne immer noch eine Idee, irgendwas. Und wenn mal nichts hilft, was auch sehr, was heißt nichts hilft, sorry, was sehr beeindruckend ist, sie haben unfassbar spannende und auch schon erfolgreiche Standardsituationen. Also sie haben auch schon zwei, drei Spiele wirklich durch Freistoßvarianten gewonnen, wo dann eben irgendwie plötzlich sich drei, vier Spieler auf erstmal vielleicht ungewöhnliche Wege gemacht haben, aber am Ende dann jeder da stand, wo er zu stehen hatte und das Tor dann gefallen ist. Also im Moment ist Napoli wirklich eine Mannschaft, die über viele Optionen kommen kann und die logischerweise wahnsinnig viel Spaß macht, gerade in so einer emotionalen Stadt wie Neapel.
Zweitbeste Mannschaft nach Standardsituationen. Nur Bologna ist da noch besser. Die stehen aber insgesamt nicht ganz so gut da wie Napoli, die eben diese komplett weiß-blanke Weste haben. Was ist sonst noch so passiert in der Serie A? Wir haben ja vor rund vier Wochen schon miteinander gesprochen.
Ja, am Wochenende gab es auch zwei Top-Spiele. Fangen wir vielleicht mal bei Lazio gegen Inter an. Es war die Rückkehr von Simone Nsagi nach Rom, nachdem er ja gefühlt, ja nicht nur gefühlt, ich glaube Anfang der Zeit, Anfang der 2000er war er ja bei Lazio erst als Spieler, dann ewig als Trainer und jetzt eben im Sommer zu Inter gekommen. Ja und Lazio hat das Ding gedreht, nach Rückstand noch. War ein sehr intensives Spiel, gab auch eine sehr heikle, ja heikle, eine sehr emotionale Szene, die danach wahnsinnig viele Tage lang diskutiert wurde. Und zwar fiel das 2-1 von Lazio, also mit dem Lazio das Spiel gedreht hat von Philippe Andersson, als ein Interspieler auf dem Boden lag. Und das hat Nachspielende dazu geführt, dass es ja schon auf dem Rasen mehr als nur Rangeleiden gab. Die sind anscheinend in der Kabine auch noch weitergegangen. Also da hat sich sehr viel aufgestaut. Und die Argumentation fand ich dann auch schlüssig von Lazio, denn Inter hat erst mal weiter gespielt. Da war Federico Di Marco schon am Boden, dann hat Inter noch weiter gespielt, ist zu einem Abschluss gekommen. Und auf dem Konter danach hat Lazio den Ball auch nicht rausgespielt, weil sie gesagt haben, ihr habt erst mal noch weiter gespielt, wir spielen jetzt auch weiter. Und da fiel das Tor. Ich muss auch dazu sagen, Federico Di Marco hatte nichts Schlimmes. Also es war jetzt nicht was Offensichtliches. Vielleicht, wo man sich denkt, wo, wo, wo, da sollte man gleich stehen bleiben. Der Schiri hat auch weiter laufen lassen. Dementsprechend war das danach sehr emotional. Aber ich finde, so wie es lief, würde ich Lazio keinen riesen Vorwurf machen, weil er gesagt hat, dass er erst mal hinter noch weiter gespielt hatte.
Kommt daher dann auch die rote Karte für Luis Felipe in der 96.
Genau, das war in der Nachspielzeit. Da gab es einige Rangeleien. Wie gesagt, im Tunnel ist es anscheinend auch noch weiter gegangen. Also da hat sich sehr viel aufgestaut. Das war so ein bisschen die Szene dieser Partie.
Da muss ich ganz kurz Jogi Hebel mit reinhauen. Jogi, welches Spiel war das? Mourinho war beteiligt. Ich glaube, Chelsea, wo es auch eine Rangelei im Spielertunnel gab, die danach unter anderem in der BBC aufgearbeitet wurde, mit genauen Karten, wann, wer, wo in die Kabine gegangen ist und wann die Spieler sich dann noch mal getroffen haben. Weißt du das noch? War das gegen City?
Das könnte gegen City gewesen sein, aber auch gegen Asien.
Ich glaube, da war auch mal was mit Asien Wenger. Genau, das einzige Mal, dass man Asien Wenger wütend gesehen hat. Absolut. Außer als jemand gesagt hat, WM nur alle zwei Jahre, finde ich doof. Da war er auch ein bisschen beleidigt. Gibt Momente. Also das war Lazio gegen Inter, 3 zu 1. Wie würdest du jetzt den bisherigen Saisonstart von Inter bewerten? Über die haben wir letztes Mal auch schon gesprochen, als positive Überraschung, dass sie trotz der Abgänge noch gut dastehen. Jetzt sind es 7 Punkte Rückstand, aber auch auf einen wirklich dominierenden Tabellenführer.
Es war die erste Niederlage der Saison. Man darf nicht vergessen, es war wieder ein Wochenende nach den Länderspiel-Pausen. Länderspiel-Pausen in Italien sind bei einigen Mannschaften, speziell bei Inter, verknüpft mit einigen Südamerikanern, die in der Nacht von Freitag auf Samstag zurückkommen. Dementsprechend saßen Lautaro Martinez und Korea nur auf der Bank. Wir hatten das Beispiel schon, dass Juve nach Neapel das Spitzenspiel ohne die fünf Südamerikaner kamen, weil die auch erst am Tag des Spiels zurückgekehrt sind. Von der Einschätzung her ist es die erste Niederlage. Das Problem für alle in Italien ist, dass Napoli und Milan diese brutale Pace haben. Also ich würde sagen Inter mit 17 Punkten nach 8 Spielen, das ist erstmal okay. Aber logisch, wenn du jemanden hast, der vorne einfach brutal aufs Gaspedal drückt, dann bist du logischerweise auch unter Druck. Ein Satz noch ganz kurz zu Lazio. Die hatten ja auch ein bisschen Wachsler drin nach dem Saisonstart, aber haben jetzt A, das Derby gewonnen und B, jetzt Inter. Also die zwei direkten ersten großen Duelle gewonnen. Logisch wichtig für Sarri. Und auch ganz interessant, ein Satz von Sarri ist mir nach dem Spiel hängen geblieben. Er hat gemeint, dieses immer mehr Spiele, immer unter der Woche drei Spiele-Rhythmus. Er hat gemeint, ich bin eigentlich da, um Spieler besser zu machen. Und wenn man aber unter der Woche nicht trainieren kann, weil man alle drei Tage spielt, wird es schwierig. Und er meinte so, er habe so ein bisschen die Lust verloren. Also das soll jetzt logisch nicht so negativ klingen in dem Umfeld, weil er macht mit Lazio auch eine gute Arbeit. Aber ich fand es schon ganz interessant, dass logischerweise ein Trainer, der eben viel über diese Entwicklung kommt, da auch einfach mal sagt, ganz ehrlich, die Richtung, in die es jetzt gerade geht, macht es mir zumindest etwas weniger Spaß als noch vor einigen Jahren.
Ja und ich finde es ganz interessant, weil das ist ja auch ein Thema, was jetzt auch alle anderen hier in der Runde gerade betrifft. Die Rückkehr der Südamerikaner, das war schon immer schwierig, aber jetzt merken wir es gerade, weil da auf einmal Quarantäne-Richtlinien mit reinkommen. Und dann wird einem erst bewusst, ey, die steigen irgendwie Donnerstagabend aus dem Flieger, irgendwie in der Nacht auf Freitag und spielen dann am Samstag wieder, was das für eine Belastung ist.
Wenn es in der Nacht auf Freitag wäre, die Juwe-Brasilianer sind das letzte Mal am Samstag gelandet und hätten am Samstag dann auch schon das Spiel gehabt. Diesmal glaube ich, die Brasilianer haben im Manau ausgespielt, da im Amazonas. Die haben glaube ich erst mal vier oder fünf Stunden gebraucht, um überhaupt erst nach Sao Paulo zurückzukommen. Es waren dann auch noch mehr Flüge. Das ist schon irre. Und wenn du gerade Mannschaften hast, wie in Italien sind es Juwe und Inter, die wirklich viele Stammspieler oder viele wichtige Kräfte Südamerikanischer haben, dann ändert sich halt so nach seinem Qualispieltag für die schon ungefähr, ich will nicht sagen alles, aber sehr, sehr viel. Da wird wirklich wahnsinnig viel durcheinander gewürfelt.
Es gab doch Charter-Flüge, die zum Teil die Vereine, zum Teil sogar zusammengebucht haben. Jogi hat sich schon entmuted.
Das weiß ich jetzt nicht. Ich weiß bloß, dass ich mit Jürgen Klopp darüber gesprochen habe, über genau dieses Thema. Bei Liverpool war es eben genauso. Die Brazerne haben bis Freitag früh gespielt quasi, in deutscher Zeit. Und sie haben versucht, bei der Liga anzufragen, ob das Spiel nicht verschoben werden kann von 13.30 auf 18.30. Die Liga hat das abgelehnt, der Gegner hat das abgelehnt. Und die Broadcaster auch, da war Jürgen Klopp dann auch sehr sauer. Weil natürlich, und das ist in England diese Besonderheit, 13.30 ist die Zeit, wo du den asiatischen Markt noch abgreifen kannst. Und wenn du da Liverpool hast, dann sagst du natürlich, das nehme ich mit, weil du weißt, die Zuschauerzahlen sind dementsprechend auch in die Höhe geschnellt. Und dementsprechend ist dann gesagt worden, ne, wir verschieben das einfach mal nicht. Hätte ein 18.30-Spiel geholfen, Jürgen Klopp sagt ja, dann hätten sie es versucht, zumindest die Spieler in den Kader zu bekommen. So nicht. Ich habe ihnen natürlich ein Namensspiel gefragt, ob... Also ich habe es während des Spiels als das Ignoranteste bezeichnet, was ich seit Ewigkeiten im Weltfußball gehört habe, weil einfach zu sagen, wir nehmen eure Spieler, ihr bezahlt die zwar und ihr schafft durch euren Mehrwert in der Liga auch, dass die Spieler überhaupt erst nominierbar sind. Trotzdem gebt ihr die nicht rechtzeitig zurück. Also ich meine, ich kann ja mal in die Runde fragen, wenn ich mal euer Auto ausleihe. Und ihr sagt mir, ich brauche es am Samstag um 13 Uhr. Und ich bringe es euch aber erst 17 Uhr und sage, pff, mir doch egal. Dann werde ich mir das Auto nicht mehr leihen. Das Problem ist aber, die Vereine müssen, weil Abstellungspflicht herrscht. Und das ist halt das große Problem. Und ich habe ihn dann eben gefragt, ob er das eben auch als ignorant empfindet. Und ob man überhaupt was machen kann. Oder ob man sich einfach nur in den Arm beißen kann. Und er meinte halt, ja man kann eben nichts machen, weil das eben das große Problem ist. Das ist seit Ewigkeiten so, dass man die Spieler eben abgeben muss. Aber dass die Spiele jetzt so nah an die Liga rangeführt werden, das ist halt einfach nicht mehr normal. Und da muss es eine Lösung geben. Und da bin ich vollkommen dabei. Ich finde, das ist wirklich einfach nur ignorant und arrogant.
Ich kann da gleich dran anhängen. Du hast gefragt, magst zwecks Charter flügen? Ja, in Spanien war es Liga-Verband LFP, der dafür gesorgt hat, dass dann zumindest am Freitag Spieler wie Fedor Valverde oder auch Casemiro pünktlich noch zurückkamen. Jetzt am Wochenende war es das zweite Mal, dass manche Spiele verschoben wurden. Barca, Villarreal und Sevilla hatten schon Spiele verschoben, jetzt Athletico und Real spielfrei gewesen, weil es einfach nicht möglich war, durch die Champions-League-Spieler am Dienstag, dass sie da am Sonntag noch spielen mit nur einem Tag dazwischen. Also ist auch in Spanien ein großes Thema. Liga-Verband hat da auch Mitteilung veröffentlicht, von wegen, man würde dagegen vorgehen, man würde die Spieler hier behalten. Hat nicht geklappt, weil ja Konmebol und FIFA da Recht bekommen haben, vom Sportgericht, glaube ich. Und deswegen die Spieler trotzdem abreißen mussten. Also es ist, wie Jogi sagt, eigentlich eine Unverschämtheit, dass da die Spieler nicht gezwungen werden, zu verreisen, dann so spät zurückkehren. Und auch deswegen sportlich überschaubare Leistungen, wenn dann Spieler, auch ein Lautaro Martinez, erstmal auf die Bank muss. Und Real und Co. haben da genauso Probleme, wenn so viele Nationalspieler immer nach Südamerika müssen und dann so spät erst zurückkommen.
Genau, bei Paris Saint-Germain war es nicht anders. Die mussten bereits am Freitagabend antreten. Zu dieser Zeit waren Neymar und Co. noch nicht ganz gelandet. Also die Brasilianer, die waren noch in der Luft und konnten nicht direkt auf dem Rasen landen, leider. Messi war auf der Tribüne, weil er, glaube ich, zwei Stunden vor Brasilien gespielt hat. Aber natürlich, dann musste Pochettino auf sechs, sieben Spieler verzichten. Das ist zu verschmerzen gegen Angers, auch wenn der Sieg alles andere als verdient war. Das besprechen wir eben noch mal ein bisschen später. Aber die spektakulärste Aktion war wieder Olympique Lyon mit Lucas Paqueta, der auch sehr spät am Freitagabend zurückkam.
Das ist übrigens auch wieder einer der vielen Vorteile des FC Bayern in der Bundesliga. Wenn du deine Mannschaft aus vornehmlich deutschen Nationalspielern zusammen machst, dann hast du nicht so viele, die durch die Welt fliegen. Man sieht es an Alfonso Davies, der wird sofort nach dem 5-0 ausgewechselt. Das ist das allererste, an das Julian Nagelsmann denkt, geil, wir können den Fonsi rausnehmen, weil wir führen jetzt schon 5-0. Das ist jetzt noch mal eine andere Thematik. Aber schon irre, wie das einfach alle europäischen Ligen beschäftigt und wie das Thema aber schon früher eines war. Und jetzt aber gerade noch mal mit den Corona-Bestimmungen und auch mit der Terminierung. Also ich habe schon das Gefühl, es ist näher gerückt an die Ligen.
Ja, genau, also ein Satz noch vielleicht dazu. Ich bin auch völlig dabei. Ich finde auch, die Ligen, ich weiß nicht, ob da manchmal vielleicht, ich habe so das Gefühl, dass da überhaupt nicht miteinander kommuniziert wird, weil zum Beispiel, es war jetzt eben Juve-Napoli, viel genau. Also eines der Topspiele fällt dann genau auf den Spieltag, wo Juve fünf Südamerikaner noch in der Luft hat sozusagen. Also die Frage ist, ich habe so das Gefühl, dass die auch alles so aneinander vorbei einfach ihr Ding machen, dass es da auch in keinster Weise irgendwie einen Austausch gibt. Und da noch mal auf das Spiel zurückzukommen, da fand ich Alegrang, den Juve-Trainer ganz gut, denn der hat die Südamerikaner gesagt, hey, ich nehme die erst gar nicht mit, weil die sind ungefähr gefühlt vor ein paar Stunden gelandet. Die sind im Kopf, keine Ahnung, nach einem Interkontinentalflug. Also ich finde, man sollte auch hin und wieder an die Spieler denken. Und dementsprechend fand ich das dann eigentlich ganz gut. Aber dem Spektakel kommt es logischerweise nicht so gut, wenn du bei einem Spitzenspiel nicht die besten Spieler aufbieten kannst.
Ja, das ist schon spannend. Wenn wir bei Juve sind, wollen wir dann auch, weil das hast du ja vorhin angesprochen, das zweite Spitzenspiel Juve gegen die Roma. Also ich gehe jetzt einfach mal davon aus, dass das das zweite Spitzenspiel ist. Adlerauge Ost-Neuwieder. Ein 1 zu 0 für Juve. Die kommen jetzt so langsam in die Spur, sind aber trotzdem noch 10 Punkte Rückstand auf Napoli.
Ja, das sind die 10 Punkte, die sie schon vor vier Spielen hatten. Aber das bedeutet jetzt auch, dass sie vier Mal in Serie gewonnen haben. Ja, bei Juve ist momentan Pragmatismus pur angesagt. Es geht einfach darum, eine Siegesserie zu starten, weil das Loch schon so groß ist. Haben jetzt zum dritten Mal in Serie zu Null gespielt. Was Juve am Anfang der Saison meilenweit davon entfernt war. Es ging los mit diesem 1-0 gegen Schelz in der Champions League, dann 1-0 im Derby gegen Turin und jetzt 1-0 gegen die Roma. Cesny, entscheidender Mann, hat eine Elfmeter gehalten beim 1-0. Der Cesny, der zu Beginn der Saison ja einige Patzer drin hatte, hat auch schon Juve-Punkte gekostet. Dementsprechend auch für ihn wahnsinnig wichtig, da auch wieder sich selbst vertrauen zu holen. Ja, war ein Spiel. Diese Elfmeterszene war auch hier der Aufreger des Abends. Denn das Foul war unstrittig von Cesny an Mkhitaryan. Aber wirklich ein Wimpernschlag später, gefühlt eine Sekunde später, drückt Tammy Abraham den Abpraller ins Tor. Aber der Schiedsrichter hat, was ja auch nachvollziehbar ist, in dem Moment schon gepfiffen. Und dann tritt der Roma-Spieler Veritou an und verschießt einen Elfmeter. Also die Roma war dann logischerweise sauer.
Wie hat Jose Mourinho das aufgenommen? Ruhig und besonnen?
Ja, das Besondere daran war, das war klar, dass Mourinho für ihn war es ein emotionales Spiel, denn er wurde vom Juventus-Publikum aufgrund seiner Trippelzeit bei Inter, ich sag's mal so, nicht wirklich freundlich empfangen. Also das war 90 Minuten, hatte der einiges von den Rängen abbekommen. Aber er hat es souverän gelöst. Er hat gesagt nach dem Spiel, ich sag gar nichts zu den Schiedsrichtern. Weil es war klar, wenn er was gesagt hätte, dann wäre das logischerweise aufgebauscht worden. Also die Roma hat in dem Fall wirklich, muss man sagen, bei dieser Szene Pech gehabt. Weil, wie gesagt, wenn er den Vorteil abwartet, dann ist er drin. Wenn er einen Elfmeter trifft, kann man auch sagen, ist er auch drin, klar. Aber den Elfmeter hat er halt eben nicht gemacht. Und dann ist es beim 1-0 halt geblieben. Und wie gesagt, Jube versucht jetzt einfach über Stabilität. Gerade nach dem 1-0 haben sie sich auch wieder gerne fallen gelassen. So ein bisschen wie gegen Chelsea. Sie versuchen, das Ganze tiefer stehend zu spielen. Dann haben dann neben Quesar Quadrado diese blitzschnellen Leute, versuchen da dann eben das Ganze so nach vorne zu bringen. Und ich kann es, muss ich sagen, ich kann der Allegri im Moment auch keinen Vorwurf machen. Denn wenn du zehn Punkte Rückstand hast, dann glaube ich, ist jetzt erstmal nicht die Zeit für Experimente. Jetzt musst du schauen, dass du eben diese Siegesserie startest. Und dann wird wahrscheinlich schon auch bei Ligue noch ein bisschen Zeit bleiben, um auch was zu entwickeln. Aber im Moment geht es einfach darum, dieses Napoli-Loch, das Napoli gerissen hat, erstmal im Idealfall irgendwie Schritt für Schritt zu verkleinern. Oder wenn Napoli das macht, was sie im Moment machen, einfach nicht größer werden zu lassen.
Ja, da wird unter anderem das Spiel gegen Inter wahrscheinlich ein wichtiges. Und die Fiorentiner wird auch einer der nächsten Gegner von Juve sein. Über die wollten wir eigentlich unbedingt aussprechen, hast du zumindest das letzte Mal gesagt.
Und dann verlieren die gegen Venezia.
Müssen wir noch über die Roma sprechen? Also wir haben es jetzt nur kurz gestreift. Die haben jetzt zweimal verloren. Zwei ihrer drei Niederlagen sich geholt.
Das sprechen wir noch an. Das war ein großer Punkt, der vor der Saison schon über der Roma stand. Die Roma hatten in der letzten Saison und auch in den letzten Jahren wahnsinnige Probleme gegen die Großen. Also in den direkten Duellen haben die so gut wie nichts geholt. Letztes Jahr haben sie von den zwölf direkten Duellen, also gegen die Top 6, eines gewonnen. Eine interessante Zahl bin ich heute noch darüber gestolpert. Anscheinend von den letzten 38 direkten Duellen untereinander, also jetzt über mehrere Spielzeiten, haben sie nur sechs gewonnen. Und da kannst du dann eigentlich nicht ganz oben mithalten, ist klar. Und das Problem, die Hoffnung war, Mourinho kommt jetzt, bringt genau in diesen großen Spielen dann vielleicht diesen Tick Überzeugung nochmal mehr. Die Roma hat gut angefangen, steht ja immer noch gut in der Tabelle. Der steht auch immer noch vor Juve, aber das Problem setzt sich fort. Sie haben das Derby verloren. Und sie haben jetzt gegen Juve auch das zweite direkte Duell verloren. Also da muss die Roma in die Spur kommen, denn ansonsten wirst du es nicht schaffen, dich da ganz vorne zu etablieren.
Gut, und jetzt noch ein kurzes Wort zu Florenz.
Ja, wir wollten sie ja loben, oder?
Du hast gesagt, wir müssten das nächste Mal über Florenz sprechen.
Ja, sehr gerne. Das war jetzt logischerweise ein Dämpfer. Schön auch für Venedig, aber wenn man vielleicht ganz kurz nach unten schaut, also da unten so ein bisschen, die kommen alle so langsam in die Spur. Spezia hat jetzt auch am Wochenende gewonnen. Venedig, glaube ich, jetzt mit acht Punkten stehen auch jetzt ganz ordentlich da. Ja, die Fiorentina, großes Thema. Dusan Vlaovic, der Top-Stürmer, der ja in ganz Europa auf dem Zettel ist. Ja, da ist ein bisschen Unruhe reingekommen ins Umfeld, weil Kommissor der Präsident der Fiorentina verkündet hat, wir reden jetzt seit Monaten drüber über eine Vertragsverlängerung. Das wird nichts mehr, so ungefähr. Das interessante daran ist, dass sein Vertrag nicht 2022 ausläuft, sondern eigentlich erst 2023. Also eigentlich ist ja noch Zeit da. Also die Fiorentina hat sich da ein bisschen eine Baustelle aufgemacht. Denn gestern hat auch der Fiorentina-Anhang seinen Unmund auch gegenüber Vlaovic gemacht. Also das war taktisch alles andere als clever. Es wird logisch stark rauf und runter spekuliert, wohin er dann wohl gehen würde. Es ist ja auch klar, dass er mittelfristig nicht in Fularenz bleiben wird, weil er wirklich eine Entwicklung hat, die glaube ich für sehr viel Höheres geschaffen ist. Aber klar, dann hast du so ein Spiel wie gestern. Die Mannschaft macht es eigentlich nicht schlecht, aber du machst die Bude nicht, dann steht er im Fokus. Er ist derjenige, der ja angeblich eben nicht verlängern will. Also ich finde, es war ein bisschen unglücklich von der Fiorentina, sich diese Baustelle selbst aufzumachen. Aber ich bleibe dabei, dass eine Mannschaft, die sehr gut anzuschauen ist, sehr gutes Pressing, die auch Qualitätsspieler hat, Bonaventura macht das sehr gut im Mittelfeld. Also man kann sich ein Fiorentinaspiel, auch wenn sie mal in Venedig verlieren, sehr, sehr gut anschauen. Weil Italiano, dort drehen haben wir kurz angerissen, da wirklich gute Arbeit macht.
Wäre das dann auch dein Tipp, wenn du sagst, schaut euch Spiele dieser Mannschaft an, da macht ihr nichts falsch? Oder auf wen würdest du da jetzt gerade setzen aktuell?
Ja, haben wir das letzte Mal auch schon gesagt. Ich würde auch, diesmal ist es ein bisschen untergegangen. Atalanta kann man da jetzt schon wieder anführen. Haben am Wochenende endlich wieder mal deutlich gewonnen. 4-1 Josep Ilicic, seine ersten zwei Tore gemacht. Das ist so, hatten auch gesehen, war sehr emotional. Da sind sehr viele Teamkollegen gleich zu ihm hin. Da ist, glaube ich, auch einiges im Hintergrund mitgesprungen. Und kann auch nur raten, schaut euch das zweite von Ilicic an, so ein typisches Ilicic-Tor aus dem Stand, ein Schlänzer von der Strafraumgrenze, links oben ins Kreuz Eck, wo du einfach gar nichts machen kannst. Also Atalanta hat Riesenverletzungsbrechen im Moment. Es ist nicht nur Robin Gossens, der lange ausfällt, es ist auch Pessina, der nationalitalinische Europameister. Jetzt ist auch noch Berra Gym City, fällt, glaube ich, mindestens einen Monat aus. Also im Moment müssen sie schauen, dass sie sozusagen ihre intensive Spielweise auch mit weniger Spielern, auch mit Schlüsselspielern nicht besetzen können. Aber ich habe das Gefühl, dass Atalanta diese kleinen Rückschläge, die sie zuletzt hatten, in der Lage ist, aufzufangen. Und ja, ein Atalantaspiel bleibe ich weiterhin dabei. Es ist eigentlich verlässliche Fußball-Spaßkultur, die man sich jedes Mal anschauen kann.
An diesen Worten werden wir dich messen, Christian. Aber die Serie A, wirklich spannende Entwicklung da. Ich würde sagen, wir lassen jetzt Alexi nicht zu lange warten bei seinem Rasenfunk-Debüt. Und wir sprechen jetzt mal, Alexi, über die Ligue 1. Was hat sich denn da zuletzt getan? Du hast ja schon angesprochen, unter anderem Péché sich schwer gegen Angers.
Ja, es ist ein bisschen ein Spiegelbild, wie der Saisonpaar ist, gewinnt fast alle seine Spiele. Ist jetzt nur einmal verloren und der Rest immer gewonnen. Aber spielerisch sehr mau, sehr glücklich. Diese Siege, oft in der Nachspielzeit, jetzt mit einem sehr glücklichen Elfmeter, der eigentlich nicht gegeben werden sollte. Und man hat irgendwie das Gefühl, dass Pochettino immer noch nicht in Paris angekommen ist. Nach zehn Monaten, da merkt man oder stellt man keine Handschrift fest. Das ist eher Zufallsaktionen, was wir insbesondere gegen Angers am Freitag gesehen haben, aber auch in den anderen Spielen. Es gab bis jetzt unter seiner Regie in zehn Monaten zwei gute Spiele. Einmal in Barcelona im Achtelfinal-Hinspiel gegen eine Mannschaft, die eh schon unterirdisch war. Und jetzt gegen Manchester City vor drei Wochen, auch wenn da die Citizens, teilweise Paris, einen Schwindeln gebracht hat. Das war auch nicht von der ersten bis zur letzten Minute Hurra-Fußball. Aber trotzdem war es okay. Ansonsten, wie gesagt, zu wenig Fußball, zu wenig Stil von Pochettino. Auch die drei vorne, Neymar, Mbappé und Messi harmonieren nicht, wie er wünscht. Und deswegen kann man sich schon Sorgen machen, was das wahre Niveau von Peugeot betrifft. Also meiner Meinung nach hat diese Mannschaft nach wie vor nicht das Potenzial, die Champions League zu übergeben.
Ja, dieses Spiel gegen City, das fand ich sehr interessant. Also es war auf hohem Niveau, man konnte sich das sehr gut angucken. Aber was mich eben wirklich verwundert hat, war am Ende steht Peugeot bei sechs Schüssen. Ich meine, man macht dann auch zwei Tore daraus und das ist dann in Ordnung. Und die reine Statistik sagt jetzt auch nicht alles über dieses Spiel aus. Da waren auch so ein paar ungenaue Aktionen mit dabei. Aber das ist ja genau eigentlich das Gegenteil von dem, was man sich erwartet, wenn man eben so viel vor allem ja auch in den Sturm investiert.
Ja, absolut. Klar kann man sich auf der einen Seite bei Peugeot Beglück wünschen, dass man so effizient ist und nicht so viele Chancen braucht, um ein Tor zu erzielen. Wenn es darauf ankommt, ich meine jetzt auf der europäischen Bühne, erwartet man schon mehr Fußball, mehr Spektakel, mehr Attraktivität. Und das hat man einfach nicht. Und das ist schon an den Tränen anzukreiden, weil er ist auch da, um seinen Stil, seine Philosophie durchzusetzen. Und die Frage ist bei Pochettino, ehrlich gesagt, hat er überhaupt eine?
Das wäre jetzt meine Frage gewesen.
Ja, also wie gesagt, seit zehn Monaten ist er da. Und er hat immer gesagt, ich brauche mindestens sechs Monate. Okay, hat er auch bekommen. Er ist nicht mal französischer Meister geworden. Muss man auch nie vergessen. Natürlich werden jetzt die Wartungen erfüllt bis jetzt. Spitzenreiter locker in der Ligue 1. In der Champions League sieht es gut aus, dass man ins Achtelfinale einzieht, sogar vielleicht als Gruppensieger. Aber wenn du auch so spielst im Frühling, dann kann das sein, dass du gegen sogar Borussia Dortmund ausscheidest im Achtelfinale.
Also bei PSG noch längst nicht alles da, wo es sein soll. Wie sieht es denn sonst so in der Liga aus? Du hast es schon angesprochen, PSG ist deutlich vorne. Erst eine Niederlage in 10 Spielen, 27 Punkte macht das dann. L'Ange auf Platz 2 mit 9 Punkten Rückstand schon deutlich dahinter. Wir haben das auch schon in den letzten Folgen immer wieder angesprochen, dass vor allem die starken Mannschaften aus der Vorsaison wirklich mit Problemen in diese Spielzeit gehen. Und das hört nicht so wirklich auf. Also egal, ob ich auf Lille gucke, ob ich auf Monaco gucke, es gibt eigentlich nur ganz wenige, die wieder. Lyon, die erholen sich jetzt langsam so ein bisschen. Aber das ist irgendwie gerade eine sehr interessante Liga-Saison, weil so viel hinter PSG passiert. Was sind denn da für dich die interessantesten Mannschaften?
Ich hoffe, für die Konkurrenzwichtigkeit des französischen Fußballs, vor allem in der Champions League, das Lyon-Monaco, das Podium komplettieren werden am Saisonende. Weil wenn es wieder eine Überraschungsmannschaft schafft, wie Lille in der letzten Saison, vom Potenzial her vielleicht in dieser Spielzeit, Niza oder Rennes, dann werden diese beiden Mannschaften, egal welche die Champions League bestreiten würde, in der Gruppenphase der Champions League maximal mit einem Punkt ausscheiden. Und das sollte man gefälligst vermeiden, weil wenn man PSG herausnimmt, in der Champions League, haben die französischen Vereine, ich glaube in den letzten fünf Jahren, von 99 möglichen Punkten 9 Punkte geholt. Das ist eigentlich eine Katastrophe.
Obwohl es im letzten Jahr diese zwei Halbfinallisten gab. Nebenvorletztes Jahr war das mit PSG und Lyon.
Man muss halt PSG und Lyon herausnehmen. Lyon habe ich vergessen. Sonst sind es Mannschaften wie Marseille, wir reden letztes Jahr. Lille fängt auch damit wieder an. Wird auch sang und klanglos ausscheiden als amtierender Meister. Da ist es schon ein Problem, da fällt das einfach an Konstanz. Deswegen Lyon und Monaco sind für mich schon Mannschaften, die wieder nach oben schieben können, die auch in der Champions League eine Rolle spielen können, weil die Geld haben, weil sie ein klares Konzept haben, sehr professionell arbeiten. Und Lyon hat sich jetzt mit der Betaboss als Trainer gefangen. Ich muss ehrlich sagen, die bieten auch einen attraktiven Fußball. Monaco hat ein bisschen mehr Schwierigkeiten. Allein, wenn man sieht, was Kevin Volland in dieser Saison leistet bzw. nicht leistet, das ist schon ein Schatten seiner selbst. Ich weiß nicht, was er durchmacht, ob er enttäuscht ist, dass er nicht mehr in einer Mannschaft ist oder was. Aber auf jeden Fall hat er in der letzten Saison 16 Treffer. Allein in der Liga 1 in dieser Saison wird er nicht mehr so lang Stammspieler sein, wenn es so weitergeht. Und da hat Kovac schon große Probleme. Natürlich war das auch in der Champions League-Falli gegen Donetsk eine Art Schock, weil man unbedingt in die Königsklasse zurückwollte. Aber für rein Potenzial muss Monaco auch wieder auf dem Podium. Und da muss man sehen, wie Marseille wirklich stark ist. Das werden wir definitiv am Sonntag wissen, beim Spiel des Jahres gegen Paris Saint-Gerland, beim Klassik. Und deswegen wäre es schon für die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit, Konkurrenzfähigkeit der französischen Liga eine gute Nachricht, wenn nicht mehr kleinere Namen auf dem Podium landen.
Ja, spannend. So ein bisschen eine andere Perspektive, als man sie ja sonst gerne hat, wo man sich dann freut über die Außenseite. Aber das Argument mit den Champions League-Abschneiden, das ist schon relativ gewaltig. Lass mal noch kurz bei Monaco bleiben, das interessiert mich. Kevin Volland, hast du angesprochen, hat erst zwei Tore gemacht in der Liga. In der Europa League noch keins. Da ist gerade Ben Yedder der erfolgreichste Torschütze. Jetzt auch nicht unbedingt überragend, aber derjenige, der noch am ehesten trifft. Monaco liegt aktuell auf Tabellenplatz 10 mit 14 Punkten. Kann man denn festmachen, woran das liegt? Ich hab zwischendurch auch mal Kritik an Alexander Nübel gelesen. Generell ist es ja immer relativ unruhig bei Monaco. Wo würdest du denn sagen, liegen die Gründe dafür, dass das mit Niko Kovac und seiner Mannschaft da jetzt gerade nicht so gut läuft?
Ja, eigentlich ist es komisch, wenn man sagt, Monaco unruhig, passt nichts zusammen. Weil da gibt es keinen Druck, da gibt es keine Fans, da gibt es keine Journalisten. Das ist einfach das Schönste für einen Fußballprofi sein. Eine fantastische Landschaft, das beste Essen der Welt. Entschuldigung, Christian, du hast auch einfach ein nettes Stadion mitten in der Stadt. Also es ist schon eine Ausnahme. Aber natürlich steckt dahinter ein reicher russischer Eigentümer, der auch Ergebnisse sehen will, der schon relativ viel Geld einsteckt und der einfach die Ziele erreichen will. Und wenn seine Mannschaft jetzt zenter ist, muss man auch relativ werden, weil zwischen Platz 1 und Platz 2 sind zwei 9 Punkte. Aber zwischen Platz 2 und 16 sind auch, glaube ich, 9 Punkte. Und Monaco mit zwei siegenden Folgen könnte wieder ganz oben nach oben kommen. Aber es ist nicht normal, dass man jetzt nach 10 Spieltagen nur auf Platz 10 steht. Da fällt das auch an, Konstanz, bei Monaco. Und da hatte auch Kovac Probleme mit der Torwart-Position, weil Alex Nübel keinen Mensch in Frankreich kannte. Dann spielt er. Sein Konkurrent Benjamin Laconte hat so viel Angst vor Nübel, dass er sofort nach Madrid zu Atlético wechselt, wo er noch weniger spielt, das ist ja klar. Und Nübel macht dann einen Patzer nach dem anderen, im August, im September. Er kriegt wirklich schlechte Noten in der französischen Presse, auch zurecht, weil er wirklich verschiedene und mehrere Patzer gemacht hat. Aber, muss man ehrlich sagen, seit zwei Spielen hat er sich stabilisiert. Scheinbar hat ihn auch die Länderspielpause gut getan. Er war überragend, muss man sagen, in Lyon trotz zwei Gegentore. Aber es hätte deutlich höher ausfallen können, zugunsten von OL. Und da hat wirklich der Ex-Schalker seine Sache richtig gut gemacht, hatte zwei, drei Weltklasse-Reflexe und gezeigt, warum Kovac ihn vertraut und vielleicht ist es das Ende seiner schlechten Zeit. Vielleicht hat er auch Zeit gebraucht, sich anzupassen, neue Liga, neue Kultur, neue Sprache und so weiter und so fort. Und man kann nur wünschen für ihn, dass er weiter starke Leistungen zeigt und er auch dafür sorgt, dass Monaco wieder nach oben kommt in Richtung Weihnachten.
Und jetzt hast du ja genau dieses Spiel gegen Lyon jetzt schon mehrfach angesprochen. Lyon hat das 2 zu 0 gewonnen. Die Tore haben gemacht Ekambi und Denayé. Und damit ist Lyon jetzt auf Tabellenplatz 16 geklettert, wobei dein Hinweis schon sehr wichtig war, zu sagen, wie eng da der Abstand ist. Das hätte ich natürlich noch unbedingt dazu sagen müssen. Also Lyon jetzt 16 Punkte, ein Sieg mehr. Und man könnte bis auf Platz 2 sogar in der Theorie springen. Also das scheint besser in der Spur zu sein. Und wir haben schon in den letzten Sendungen gehört, dass es da eine große Begeisterung auch für Peter Boss gab und auf das Projekt, was er da jetzt umsetzt. Wir als deutsche Fußballfans gucken da ja ein bisschen kritischer drauf, weil wir zwar gesehen haben, was da gut gehen kann, aber halt auch, wo die Probleme liegen in Konterabsicherung. Und dass es eben dann auch sehr davon abhängt, dass man auch seine Chancen verwandelt, die man mit dem sehr offensiven Spielstil herausspielt. Ist denn das jetzt der Peter Boss, so wie wir ihn auch bei Leverkusen und bei Dortmund gesehen haben? Oder siehst du da eine Entwicklung bei ihm?
Das ist ja gar keine Entwicklung, weil er auf jeden Fall sein Spielstil durchsetzen will mit aller Macht. Deswegen hatte er in den ersten zwei, drei Monaten Millionen große Probleme. Er hat erst mal festzustellen, dass die Spieler im Training faul aus Deutschland sind. Das ist einfach ein Fakt, sodass er seinen Ton rauer werden musste. Er musste auch zeigen, wer der Boss ist. Gott sei Dank hat er verdient die Unterstützung seiner Bosse. Aber die Spieler haben echt ein paar Wochen gebraucht, um zu verinnerlichen, wer es wirklich will, was ist komplett konträr zum Vorgänger Rüdiger. Was er spielen will, mit diesem Gegenpressing, sehr viel Intensität, sehr viel Tempo. Dadurch müssen die Spieler mehr schwitzen als in der Vergangenheit im Training. Und auch der Boss hat gesagt, dass er versteht, dass die Fans sauer sind auf die Spieler, was sehr schlecht ankam in der Kabine. Dann gab es aber immer mehr gute Ergebnisse. In der Europa League zwei Spiele, zwei Siege. In der Liga jetzt auch. Ich glaube, in den letzten fünf Spielen haben wir 13 Punkte geholt. Ganz knapp, völlig unverdient bei Paris Saint-Germain. Wir haben verloren in der allerletzten Minute. Und man merkt schon die Entwicklung. Und jetzt ist Peter Boss wieder fest im Sattel. Er ist wieder völlig souverän. Und ich glaube schon, dass Lyon jetzt mittelfristig, wenn man davon sprechen kann, von Konkurrenz, aber wird sicherlich der Favorit sein, um Vizemeister zu werden.
Ich finde es so interessant, aber es kommen ja so viele tolle, junge französische Spieler in alle europäischen Top-Ligen. Und jetzt zu hören, dass dann das Training oder die Einstellung im Training bei einer der wichtigsten Mannschaften so viel anders sein soll, als in anderen Ligen. Das hätte ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht erwartet.
Ein gutes Beispiel, Max. Er hat sich leider die letzte Woche im Amt nie verletzt. Aber ich war verwundert, warum er nie im Kader steht. Und dann hat Belegrino gesagt, er hatte so viel Trainingsrückstand, bzw. musste er sich erst mal an unserem Rhythmus gewöhnen. Und das war nicht anders unbedingt bei Encuncu am Anfang bei Leipzig. Wenn man sieht, was er jetzt für eine Weltklasse Leistung an der anderen zeigt, das war auch nicht anders unbedingt bei Konaté. Obwohl, Opa Meccano hat auch und Konaté das Glück, dass die vorhin Salzburg waren und diesen Rhythmus schon kannten. Aber wenn Bouna Sarr dermaßen Schwierigkeiten in München hat, weil er eine andere Sportart als bei Olappi Marseille ist einfach so, vor allem im Training. Und deswegen diese jungen Spieler, diese Juwelen, diese hohen Talente, die jetzt auch in Dortmund hat mit Gulli Bali, unter anderem der auch große Schwierigkeiten hat mit dem Laufbenzum bei VB, die brauchen Zeit, um sich dran zu gewöhnen. Aber wenn die angekommen sind, dann in ihren jeweiligen Vereinen, dann werden sie sicherlich eine wichtige Rolle spielen, weil sie auch die Chancen bekommen auf Einsätze, im Gegensatz zu den Premier League Clubs oder allein bei Paris Saint-Germain, wie es bei Encuncou, Diaby oder Comandefalva war.
Ja, das waren dann schon ziemlich viele sehr gute Beispiele.
Da hast du recht.
Also jetzt haben wir die großen Namen so ein bisschen besprochen, außer Marcel, die sind noch so ein bisschen runtergefallen. Ein paar Minuten haben wir noch. Wer Marcel, noch so eine Mannschaft, wo du sagst, auf die sollten wir jetzt auf jeden Fall nochmal gucken oder gibt es vielleicht auch irgendein Überraschungsteam in der Ligue 1, im positiven oder negativen?
Marcel glaube ich nicht. Ich habe zwar einen guten Kader, den verrückten, der zweite El Loco namens Sainte Pauli auf der Bank. Wie gesagt, die spielen gegen PSG erst in Europa, bei Lazio am Donnerstag in der Europa League und dann gegen PSG im Stadt Velodrom am Sonntag. Was mir wieder bei OM gefällt, diese Stimmung in dem Stadion. Du hast über 60.000, das ist wirklich ein Hexenkessel. Und diejenigen, die noch nie in Marcel waren, bitte hingehen. Das ist zwar dort richtig heiß zu, aber da kriegt man sehr schnell Gänsehaut. Man hat halt über 15 neue Spieler geholt in diesem Sommer. Und wenn der beste Spieler von OM, Matteo Gendusi heißt, der bei Hertha nicht so schlecht war, aber trotzdem einen merkwürdigen Charakter hat, dann kann man sich schon Sorgen machen um die nahe Zukunft von OM. Aber könnte noch klappen mit dem dritten Platz, wenn vieles gut läuft, wenn Monaco nach wie vor Strauch hält. Aber ich glaube eher, das macht sie erneut in die Europa League nur einzugehen. Wir werden am Saisonende. Deswegen sehe ich fast sogar Nizza als interessante Mannschaft. Natürlich habe ich gerade in Troyes verloren beim Aussteiger. Aber es ist eine Mannschaft, die sehr viel investiert hat, sich klug verstärkt hat auf strategischen Positionen. Und die haben natürlich den Trainer, der amtierende Meister von Lille, Christophe Galtier. Und die haben dort unheimlich viele finanzielle Möglichkeiten. Und ich glaube, dieser Saison wird es auf jeden Fall für einen einstelligen Platz reichen, vielleicht sogar Europabukal. Aber in den nächsten zwei, drei Jahren wird Nizza in großer Wahrscheinlichkeit in der Champions League zum ersten Mal dabei sein.
Hi, schöne Prognosen kriegt man hier von dir, Alexi. Das gefällt mir. Dann sag uns noch, wahrscheinlich war jetzt die Mannschaft schon mit dabei. Welches Team sollte man verfolgen, wenn man sich für die Ligue 1 interessiert, was man jetzt vielleicht nicht direkt auf der Platte hat? Also PSG überrascht jetzt ja keinen. Die kennen wir grob.
Ja, es sind verschiedene, aber wenn man aus deutscher Sicht nicht so gut kennt, würde ich die schon verfolgen, weil die auch einen interessanten Fußball bieten. Und mit Cristobal Garcia als Trainer ist es immer ein interessanter Fußball zuletzt gewesen. Man hat auch noch bekannte Gesichter wie Dante, der gefällt 58 ist, aber immer noch Leistung bringt. Und muss man auch schauen, wie diese Mannschaft sich entwickelt. Aber ich glaube, die haben auch sehr viele Jugendtalente und die sind sehr interessant. Und wie gesagt, auch Roland Piclion, die Mannschaft der Stunde in Frankreich, weil die auch einen Ausnahmespieler haben in ihren Reihen. Der heißt Lucas Paqueta und der könnte noch für viele positive Schlagzeile in Frankreich sorgen in den nächsten Monaten.
Sehr gut. Das werden wir mal näher im Auge halten. Und es ist schön, mal über die Liga anzusprechen und nicht irgendwelche Ausschreitungen thematizieren zu müssen. Das war in den letzten beiden Folgen so. Dann lasst uns mal auf die Premier League schauen. Jogi, deine Stunde hat geschlagen. Wir werden unter anderem sprechen müssen, glaube ich, über so manchen Investor, der da gekommen ist. Und vielleicht auch die Reaktion der Fans vor Ort. Newcastle United gehört jetzt, ja, also, einer Institution, die von sich behauptet, nicht mit Saudi-Arabien und der Staatsführung zusammenzuhängen. Und dann gibt es aber im Personalunion da ganz viele Leute, die wichtig in der Politik in Saudi-Arabien sind und in der Wirtschaft und auch in der Investorengruppe sind. Und das wird sehr kritiklos gefeiert von den Fans dort. Obwohl man ja bei Saudi-Arabien, Stichwort Knochensäge, da kann man ja durchaus so manches Kritikmoment auch vorbringen. Da gab es jetzt auch jüngst erst im Liga-Ausschuss auch eine kleine, ein Widerstand bei manch anderen Clubs gegenüber dieser Übernahme. Wie bewertest du denn jetzt auch mit ein bisschen Tagen Abstand, was da bei Newcastle United passiert ist?
Also das ist wirklich denkbar schwierig, ehrlich gesagt, weil man das wirklich trennen muss. Also erstmal, in England, die Fans natürlich, die sind natürlich begeistert, die Newcastle-Fans, was irgendwo auch zu verstehen ist. Dazu muss man aber auch den Engländer verstehen. Man muss vielleicht die deutsche Brille mal absetzen. Wenn du in Deutschland einen Investor hast, egal welcher der ist, das kann der honorigste Mensch überhaupt sein, dann rüpfen trotzdem alle im Nase. In England haben alle Clubs einen Besitzer. Dementsprechend sind die das schon mal gewohnt. Das schockt die überhaupt nicht mehr. Dann kommt natürlich noch dazu, dass da auch nicht jeder honorig war, der jemals einen Club übernommen hat. Zum Beispiel Abramovic, der so als der absolute Musterbesitzer gilt. Bei dem ist jetzt zum Beispiel auch nicht klar, wie der an sein Vermögen gekommen ist. Das heißt, solche Geschichten wie, das ist eine Person, die hat vielleicht Dreck am Stecken, will aber jetzt den Verein übernehmen. Das kennt der englische Fan eigentlich schon. Deswegen sind die einfach mal da diesbezüglich nicht geschockt. Das gibt es einfach nicht mehr. Und da sind die einfach drüber hinweg. Dann kommt natürlich dazu, dass bei Newcastle Mike Ashley, ich weiß nicht, wer den kennt, der hat einen Sportartikelvertrieb, der quasi jeden einzelnen Sportartikelhändler in England aus dem Markt gedrängt hat, mit seinen Dumpingpreisen. Der ist da disbezüglich in England schon mal nicht unbedingt sehr begeistert empfangen worden. Dann aber kommt dazu, dass er bei Newcastle, gibt es eine schöne Statistik, seit 2010 nichts in den Club selber netto investiert hat, sondern, jetzt kommt es noch viel verrückter, der hat quasi das Stadion nach seiner Firma eben umbenannt und hat dabei nicht gesagt, ich gebe euch 20 Millionen pro Jahr, sondern er hat gesagt, ihr zahlt mir bitte jetzt Namensrechte, dass euer cooles Stadion so heißen darf wie meine Firma. Das heißt, das hat er Schritt für Schritt immer wieder gemacht. Er hat immer wieder Geld rausgezogen aus dem Club und hat natürlich dann einfach das Ganze nur noch als Investment gesehen, hat nichts investiert, sondern eher sich quasi bezahlen lassen. So, und dann kommt natürlich jetzt irgendjemand aus Saudi-Arabien, von dem man weiß, die haben ein Vermögen von 70.000 fast, wie heißt es wieder, wann ist es schön? Fantastikarden, glaube ich. Fast Tantillionen, so ist es gerade. So, und dann kommt der natürlich daher und sagt, und man vermutet, dass die auch bereit sind, das zu investieren. Ob sie es tun, weiß kein Mensch. Und dass natürlich dann ein Newcastle-Fan, der in den überletzten Jahren mit gebeutet worden ist, dass der sich dann erstmal freut, kann ich vielleicht sogar verstehen. Da muss man auch dazu wissen, dort an der Teinside sind jetzt nicht unbedingt die allergebildetsten, das ist natürlich jetzt schon sehr polemisch, wie ihr wisst, was ich meine. Die sind alles so Brexit-Befürworter und so. Das ist eine sehr gebeuterte Gegend dort, wirtschaftlich jetzt nicht unbedingt sehr stark. Und dass die natürlich dann erstmal sagen, Gott sei Dank, Newcastle lebt wieder, unsere Religion hat wieder einen Sinn, kann man irgendwo nachvollziehen, dabei davon aber natürlich nicht vergessen, dass dieses Regime Blut an den Händen hat. Das ist ein Massenmörder, wie es Uli gestern schön gesagt hat, und das bleibt er auch. Dann, trotzdem, die nächste Windung, muss ja nicht heißen, dass er deswegen auch vielleicht der Besitzer ist. Das heißt nicht, dass ich das dann reinwaschen möchte, nicht umsetzten, ja, aber das ist halt genau der Sinn, Sportswash wie es so schön heißt, also über ein Besitzertum, über ein gutes Engagement irgendwo auf der Welt, das, was zu Hause ist, einfach zu verbessern, das ist ja absolut das Ziel bei diesem Regime. Und ja, ich kann verstehen, dass der eine oder andere sagt, diese Menschenrechtssituation ist für mich einfach absolut überbordend. Ich kann natürlich aber auch den Newcastle-Fan verstehen, der das vielleicht gar nicht weiß, sondern der es einfach ignoriert und sagt, endlich hat mein Trikot wieder einen Wert.
Ja, vor allem wenn man jetzt mal versucht, weil jetzt haben wir das Politische schon mit besprochen, wenn man es versucht, aufs Sportliche zu reduzieren, dann siehst du zwei Abstiege von Newcastle United 2008, 2009 und 2015, 2016, also in der jeweiligen Saison. Es ging dann jeweils in der nachfolgenden Saison als Erster in der Championship wieder nach oben. Aber die Ergebnisse sind ja nicht prickelnd. Platz 10, Platz 13, Platz 13, Platz 12. Und aktuell liegt man auf dem vorletzten Platz mit nur drei Punkten aus acht Spielen. Das heißt, wir haben hier keine Luxussituation, sondern wir haben eine sportlich sehr prekäre Situation, die durch eine wirtschaftliche Besonderheit eben durch die Art und Weise, wie der bisherige Investor weniger Investor war als Nutznießer des Vereins, die das Ganze nochmal so ein bisschen sportlich einordnet. Wo steht denn da Newcastle United? Und wenn wir jetzt mal nicht irgendwelche Zukunftstransfers mit einpreisen, von denen wir ja gar nicht wissen, ob sie kommen und wie gut die dann auch funktionieren, wie ist es denn gerade sportlich, um die bestellt?
Ich mag den, ich glaube, dass die Spieler den mögen. Er heißt so einer der besten Man-Manager der Liga. Aber er selbst hat mal in einem Interview 2010, glaube ich, gesagt, Taktik ist nicht meine große Stärke. Dieser Satz wird ihm natürlich jährlich um die Ohren gehauen. Und genauso sieht es auch aus. Ich sage immer, das ist ein Defensiv-Team, das defensive Probleme hat. Und damit ist ja eigentlich schon viel erklärt. Er versucht immer hinten sehr gut dicht zu halten und dann schnell auszulösen mit zwei, drei Spielern bloß. Die versuchen, schnell zu überbrücken. Und dann rücken die anderen nach. Das ist einfach A, total durchschaubar. Und B, hat natürlich auch die Qualität nicht im Kader, um das so durchsetzen zu können.
Schlechteste Abwehr der Liga.
Ja, das ist eben genau der Punkt. Wenn er selber sagt, wir sind ein Defensiv-Team und du bist die schlechteste Abwehr der Liga, was soll ich dazu noch sagen? Ich glaube, dass da einfach viel Missmanagement betrieben wird, wenn die ein System hätten. Der Kader ist gar nicht so schlecht. Da sind schon Fußballer drin. Mit so einem Al Miron oder so einem Callum Wilson vorne drin. Das sind schon Fußballer, die können was. Die haben ja schon auch investiert. Weil die Einnahmen der Premier League so überbordend sind, dass du es machen kannst. Die haben schon investiert in den letzten Jahren. Aber Joey Linton für 50 Millionen, was es knapp waren, der überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Also das ist auch nicht unbedingt so richtig clever eingekauft worden. Das muss man schon auch sagen.
Also das könnte dann eine sehr zähe und lange Saison werden. Glaubst du, dass das der erste Schritt sein wird, dass sich dann auf der Trainerposition da was tut?
Das heißt ja jetzt schon immer. Das hieß es ewig, Mike Ashley hatte nicht mal mehr so viel Bock, dass er sich darum kümmert, ob er überhaupt den Trainer entlässt. Und jetzt hört man ja schon, dass die ersten Namen da irgendwie umgeistern. Und dementsprechend kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass da jetzt irgendwann mal was passiert, weil der passt ja auch nicht zu diesem Image, das dieser Club jetzt dann haben wollen wird. Nämlich einfach halt Aufbruch, internationale Klasse und so weiter und so fort. Also ich kann mir schon gut vorstellen. Aber natürlich, die haben ja mit dieser Situation, die du ja gerade angesprochen hast, mit Blick auf die Tabelle, aktuell ein ganz gutes Argument, das dann wirklich zu tun. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass du Rang 7 bist und sagst, wir wollen einfach da einen anderen Namen auf der Payroll haben, sondern du hast ja wirklich auch ein Argument etwas zu tun.
Gut, das werden wir verfolgen, wie es bei Newcastle in allen Belangen weitergeht. Die sind jetzt auf jeden Fall wieder auf der europäischen Fußballlandkarte, zumindest was die Nachrichtenlage angeht. Sportlich müssen wir da mal abwarten, was da noch kommt. Was ist sonst noch so wichtig, wenn wir jetzt auf die Premier League gucken? Wenn ich mir das Tabellenbild angucke, dann überrascht da immer noch Brighton & Huff. Über die haben wir das letzte Mal schon gesprochen. Die sind immer noch auf Rang 4. Aber ansonsten sortiert es sich so ein bisschen ein. Chelsea auf 1 mit 19 Punkten, Liverpool dahinter 18, City mit 17, Tottenham auf Platz 5, dann mit 15 Punkten, United mit 14, dann kommen West Ham und Everton. Das sieht dann so mit der Ausnahme Brighton relativ erwartbar aus. Was steckt denn hinter diesen bloßen Zahlen? Wer ist gerade deiner Meinung nach am besten in Form?
Also ich habe Liverpool und Chelsea gehabt am Wochenende. Chelsea, muss man schon sagen, hatten gegen Brentford ein Spiel, das am Anfang ziemlich tuchel-like war. Sie kontrollieren, sie dominieren, sie gehen in Führung. Und dann hatte ich so das Gefühl, okay, sie schalten jetzt einen Gang zurück und versuchen, es zu verwalten. Und dann kam wirklich eine der besten letzten Viertelstunden, die ich jemals gesehen habe und die ich jemals von einem Aufsteiger gesehen habe. Also Brentford war sehr beeindruckend. Aber Eduard Mendy, der das super da hinten gemacht hat, der, glaube ich, fünf Weltklasse-Paraden hatte und im Endeffekt den Dreier gesichert hat, das ist schon ein Holz, aus dem ein Meister gemacht werden kann. Also, dass du so ein Spiel dann doch noch über die Bühne bringst, wie du das gemacht hast, ist sehr beeindruckend. Das ist so diese Abgezocktheit, die ich wirklich bewundere. Und auf der anderen Seite Liverpool, denen man sagen muss, die gewinnen 5-0 gegen Watford, als wäre das gar nichts. Und so wie die Rollen momentan, ist das auch beeindruckend. Es sind zwei unterschiedliche Ausgangslagen. Die einen hat einfach offensiv überbordend, defensiv Liverpool noch mit einem Fragezeichen zu versehen manchmal. Chelsea einfach diese Abgezocktheit, dass die sich diese Dinge einfach dann wirklich nehmen und sich dort eben nicht erwischen lassen. Also das sind so zwei Gegenpole, die mich momentan schon beeindrucken, ehrlich gesagt. Auf jeweils die ganz eigene Art und Weise.
Ich habe einen Podcast gehört, ich weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht, wo er war. Ah, das Squalke-Football-Podcast war das. Da haben sie die aktuelle beste Mannschaft der Liga zusammengestellt. Da waren Mendy vor Alesson unwidersprochen von allen drei Hows auf Platz 1. Der muss wirklich eine fantastische Saison spielen. Du hast es ja gerade auch am Beispiel dieses Brentford-Spiels dann genannt. Auf der anderen Seite, bei Liverpool haben wir alle, glaube ich, mitbekommen, dass Mosala jetzt ein paar ganz gute Aktionen wieder hatte. Das ist das eine oder andere vielleicht an einem vorbeigeflogen auf Twitter. Das verdeutlicht auch ganz gut diesen Unterschied. Wir haben hier fast heiß und kalt die einen, die Abwehrmaschine, die anderen. Das Offensivfeuerwerk ist ein bisschen vereinfacht, das ist mir schon klar. Was ist bei Manchester City los? Die hatten ja eigentlich dann einen guten Lauf, nachdem sie ja mit einer frühen Niederlage, so ein bisschen mit Handicap in die Saison gegangen sind. Jetzt jüngst allerdings auch wieder zwei Unentschiedenen. Und vor allem natürlich das Spiel gegen Liverpool war da. Also das war einfach nur für einen neutralen Beobachter richtig schön anzusehen, weil es in beide Richtungen ging.
Ja, absolut. Du hast jetzt wieder gewonnen gegen Badelay, was ja eigentlich absolut klar war, dass es so kommen würde. Da tun sie sich eigentlich meistens sogar richtig leicht. Das war sogar verhältnismäßig moderat. Also insgesamt sind die natürlich eine Mannschaft, mit der man immer rechnen muss, klar.
Okay, gut, da sind wir uns einig. Wer sind denn so für dich gerade die spannenden Teams? Gibt es auch jemanden außerhalb der erwartbaren Namen, wo du sagst, auf die lohnt sich gerade ein Blick?
Also Brentford ist mit das sympathischste, coolste, was ich jemals gesehen habe, muss man wirklich sagen. Weil ich habe das ja, wenn wir vorher bei Newcastle schon waren, ich habe das im Spiel auch genauso gesagt, denn Brentford ist genau der Gegenentwurf. Newcastle, was man vermutet, dass jetzt kommen wird, holt die große Geldbörse raus und kauft einfach alles, was bei 3 noch keinen Vertrag unterschrieben hat, irgendwo anders. Bei Brentford ist es eben genau das Gegenteil. Das ist ein Club, der hat das kleinste Budget der Liga, aber hat so einen krass coolen Plan, dass die einfach funktionieren. Die hatten, ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele es waren, ich glaube, Zanka Jorgensen, der Spieler, der jetzt quasi ablösefrei gekommen ist, der hatte die meisten Premier League-Spiele. Zuvor hatte zum Beispiel Ivan Toni gerade mal zwei Spiele in der Premier League absolviert. Und das sagt ja schon eine Menge aus. Eine sehr unerfahrene Mannschaft, aber durch dieses System, durch diese Art und Weise Fußball zu spielen, die ganz anders ist, als beim Rest der Liga, kommen die irgendwie dort sehr sympathisch rüber, mit sehr viel Wucht. Und da ist immer Spektakel. Und das ist einfach wirklich sehr beeindruckend. Und da mal ein Spiel zu sehen, wer es noch nicht getan hat, lohnt sich auf jeden Fall.
Die haben ja auch diesen datenbasierten Ansatz im Scouting gehabt, das hat uns Uli schon erzählt, im Ligatour Nummer 1. Wenn du jetzt sagst, der Fußball unterscheidet sich so deutlich, kannst du das an zwei, drei Beispielen erklären?
Ich hab mit einem Scout telefoniert aus England, der das ganz gut auf den Punkt gebracht hat. Die versuchen wirklich einfach, das Chaos irgendwie planbar zu machen. Also es ist sehr, sehr viele lange Bälle. Es ist sehr häufig, dass sie sich hinten erst mal verschanzen, warten und dann jetzt irgendwie gehen, sofort nach vorne schnell auszulösen auf einen Toni, der den Ball ablegt. Derjenige, der den Ball bekommt, schiebt ihn sofort wieder nach vorne, auf die Außenbahn. Und dann ist der Gegner so überrascht davon, mit diesen zwei Kontakten, dass es so schnell geht, dass diese Mannschaft halt so viel Wucht erzeugen kann. Auch mit diesen Spielern, mit dem Bonbon und eben mit Toni, die sehr schnell sind und eben sehr viel Dynamik haben, dass die Gegner da sehr, sehr häufig überlaufen. Und kurioserweise, sie haben so mit die wenigsten Abschlüsse der Liga, was echt verrückt ist, und trotzdem mit die beste Chancenverwertung. Also wenn die kommen, so im Boxen würde man sagen, Konterboxer, wenn die kommen, dann kriegst du so eine gewischt. Seit der Liverpool wirklich auch selbst überrascht bei diesem 3 zu 3, die hatten nicht so viele Chancen, aber die Chancen, die sie hatten, die waren so gut, dass sie wirklich einfach auch fast zu machen waren. Und das ist das Besondere an dieser Mannschaft, dass man immer denkt, ja, jetzt ist der Aufsteiger in seiner Situation, die werden hinten reingedrückt und dann kommen die und wischen die eine, dass du gerade noch so schaust. Und das ist wirklich so beeindruckend. Die letzte Viertelstunde, man denkt, die sind eigentlich raus aus der Partie gegen Chelsea. Und die drücken Chelsea so sehr, dass man denkt, wer ist hier eigentlich Aufsteiger und wer ist Champions League-Sieger? Also habe ich selbst gesehen, wir hatten noch mal drei richtig hochkarätige Chancen, die man hier alle rausholt. Und es hätte gut auch gerne 3-1 für Branford ausgehen können am Schluss, wenn die die alle gemacht hätten.
Okay, ich habe irgendwie auch das Gefühl, wir haben gerade auch deinen Tipp gehört, wie man sich mal so angucken könnte in der Premier League. Ich möchte das kurz mit einer Statistik unterstreichen. Man muss bei Expected Goals und Expected Points immer sehr vorsichtig sein. Aber der Unterschied ist so krass, dass ich es hier jetzt doch mal zitieren kann. Nach Expected Points, also eben der statistischen Wahrscheinlichkeit, mit der man Spiele gewonnen oder verloren hätte, auf Grundlage der abgegebenen Torschüsse, läge Branford hinter City und Liverpool auf Rang 3 in der Premier League. Also das ist die Statistik zu dem, was du gerade beschrieben hast.
Dazu auch noch sehr sympathisch dieses ganze Konstrukt drum herum, wie du es eben gerade schon angesprochen hast, mit diesem Datenbasierten Ansatz. Thomas Frank, einer der sympathischsten Trainer der Liga, den wir auch schon getroffen haben, sehr cooler Typ. Also da ist wirklich was am wachsen und wie gesagt ohne viel Geld, sondern einfach nur mit, wir schauen auf Daten, wir treffen den Spieler, schauen, wie ist der so drauf. Okay, das könnte ein cooler Typ sein, ich glaube, der will arbeiten, den holen wir. Meistens unterklassig, meistens mit dem Ziel, den Marktwert zu erhöhen, um ihn zu verkaufen und einfach ein System passend zu sein. Das ist wirklich etwas, was Spaß macht, weil die ganz anders sind als der Rest. Irgendwann wurde immer noch gesagt, man kauft einfach nur blind ein. Das ist da überhaupt nicht so.
Also ein flammendes Plädoyer für Brentford. Danke dir, lieber Jogi. Eine Liga fehlt uns jetzt noch, Nils Kern. Er hat sich selbst ans Ende dieser Sendung gesetzt. Deswegen denke ich, er ist damit klargekommen, dass er jetzt so lange schweigen musste. Nils, warum ist La Liga so schlecht?
Ja, erst mal muss ich dich wirklich wünschen, Max. Du hast genau die richtige Reihenfolge gefunden. Denn bei den internationalen Ligen fallen in Italien am meisten Tore. Dann kommt Frankreich, dann England. Und dann mit irgendwie 2,2 Türchen ist La Liga ganz unten am Schluss. Und das hat verschiedene Gründe.
Ich würde gern sagen, dass es geplant war, purer Zufall.
Ja, bestimmt, bestimmt. Das hat verschiedene Gründe. Einerseits hat La Liga viele Talente in den letzten Jahren verloren. Da freut sich speziell der Jogi drüber. Ferran Torres, Marco Correa, Brian Hill, Sergio Reguilón, die spielen in der Premier League. Auch Superstars wie Neymar, Ronaldo, Messi, Ramos haben ja nicht nur für Spektakel, sondern auch einige Tore gesorgt. Es wurde am wenigsten ausgegeben im Sommer im Vergleich zu den anderen Top-Ligen. Man hat im Schnitt die ältesten Spieler in La Liga. Ja, und irgendwie die große Zeit scheint so vorbei, wo Real und Barca regelmäßig Champions League gewinnen. Jetzt gab es zwar mal den Europa-League-Sieg von Villarreal, aber trotzdem ist da irgendwie La Liga auf dem absteigenden Ast. Es fallen wenig Tore. Es ist sehr überschaubarer, sehr risikoarmer Fußball. Viele 1-0-Siege, wo lange die 0-0en stehen, da gibt es zwar immer noch ein paar Last-Minute-Tore. Das war zuletzt mal wieder so der Fall. Aber irgendwie ist das oft sehr bieder. Manche Teams haben gerade mal irgendwie sieben Abschlüsse pro Spiel. Das sind Elche, Cádiz, Levante, Granada. Auch die versuchen, mit ganz wenigen einfachen Mitteln Erfolg zu haben, den Punkt erst mal zu halten. Irgendwie kann ich die Rasenfunk-Zuhörer nicht so überzeugen, jetzt regelmäßig La Liga zu schauen. Wobei jetzt nächstes Wochenende Klassico und auch noch Atletico gegen Real Sociedad da auch noch ein spitzes Spiel. Es gibt schon immer mal vereinzelte Gründe.
Ja, das ist natürlich eine Frage der Perspektive. Aber diese Torarmut, die ist schon wirklich heftig. 11 von 20 Teams haben weniger als 10 Tore erzielt nach acht bzw. neun gespielten Spielen. Das geht noch ein bisschen auseinander, hast du ja auch schon angesprochen. Da gab es verschobene Spiele unter anderem. Jetzt könnte man ja aber auch die Diskussion aufmachen. Vielleicht hören wir da auch ein bisschen zu sehr den Chefredakteur von realtotal.de sprechen gerade, wenn du sagst, ach, ist das alles auf dem Absteigen. Man könnte doch auch sagen, hey, wir haben Real, aber Sociedad nicht mal dritt auf Rang 1 gerade mit drei Punkten Vorsprung. Wir haben Sevilla auf Rang 3, wir haben Ossasuna auf 5. Dann Weihekano, über die haben wir schon in den letzten Folgen manchmal gesprochen. Könnte man ja auch sagen, endlich mal wieder eine spannende Liga.
Absolut, La Liga hatte ja so gesehen schon im vergangenen Frühjahr den spannendsten Meisterschaftskampf in Europa, nachdem sich dann Frankreich irgendwann verabschiedet hatte, wo wirklich vier Teams theoretische noch Chancen hatten. Und auch aktuell wieder L'Areal ganz oben. Das gab es zwar auch schon in der vergangenen Hinrunde. Da war Real Sociedad schon sechs Spieltage mal auf Platz eins. Also aktuell, dass die Favoriten mal ein bisschen schwächeln, ist ganz normal. Die haben ja auch noch Verletzte, jede Menge bei Barca, bei Real. Atletik noch nicht so richtig in die Spur gefunden. Aber auch die kommen jetzt langsam. Und ja, das nutzen eben andere Teams aus. Rayo Vallecano als der Aufsteiger mit 16 Punkten. Die haben jedes ihrer vier Heimspiele gewonnen. Sind da absolut vielleicht so das Gegenbeispiel von dem, was ich eben gesagt habe, sehr überschaubarer, risikoarmer, biederer Fußball. Die machen einfach Risiko, trauen sich was. Und wenn sie dann doch eins kassieren, dann machen sie trotzdem noch zwei, drei Fonds. Also Heimspiele sind da absolute Festspiele aktuell. Ich war selbst schon dabei, hab Falcao gesehen, wie er getroffen hat und wie er gefeiert wurde. Also Rayo Vallecano macht aktuell mit am meisten Spaß in La Liga. Ist auch sogar noch, wenn man jetzt auf die Formtabelle schaut, die letzten fünf Partien noch ein Pünktchen besser als Real Sociedad. Auch Osasuna da noch mit dabei. Also es gibt natürlich positive Aspekte aus La Liga.
Ich merke aber schon, die möchtest du klein halten. Das wird hier ganz schnell abgefrühstückt. Wie ist denn das generell gerade die Stimmung rund um die Liga interessiert mich? Weil wir hatten jetzt natürlich die große Aufregung. Wir haben auch immer noch, also es ist auch nicht so, dass sich jetzt alles schon beruhigt hätte, weil wir hatten ja nicht nur das Thema Neymar und MVP, was unterschiedlich, äh, entschuldigung Messi und MVP, was unterschiedlich ausgegangen ist, sondern wir hatten ja auch Super League Pläne, die es immer noch gibt. Wir haben da auch Klagen, da geht es auch fröhlich hin und her zwischen UEFA und dem, nicht nur dem spanischen Verband, sondern vor allem ja den jeweiligen Mannschaften. Wird das positiv aufgefasst, dass man gerade wieder mehr andere Mannschaften sieht, die auch Spannung garantieren? Und ich hab gerade das Gefühl, dass es eigentlich bei jedem Spieltag so ist, dass Real und Barca stolpern könnten, weil sie es jetzt auch schon so häufig getan haben. Und das macht ja eigentlich auch was mit dem gesamten Markt, dass man sich denkt, die spielen jetzt in Granada, das muss ich mir jetzt gar nicht angucken, sondern gerade weil sie das spielen, denke ich mir, ja, das schauen wir jetzt mal an.
Ja, das könnte man sich denken. Also Real hat schon drei Spiele nicht gewonnen, Barca schon vier Spiele nicht gewonnen, Atletico auch drei. Da ist schon immer mal stolper Gefahr bei jedem Spiel, eigentlich egal, ob du beim Aufsteiger bist, bei Nullspielst oder zu Hause, wie er Real empfängt. Aber das heißt jetzt trotzdem nicht, dass die Stadien wirklich gefüllt sind. Jetzt war jetzt der erste Spieltag, wo wieder 100 Prozent erlaubt waren in spanischen Stadien. Trotzdem, in Vigo war nicht mal 50 Prozent erreicht, im Camp Nou sowieso nicht. Also da ist einfach auch noch ein bisschen die Euphorie überschaubar, weil einfach auch das Sportliche vielleicht nicht mehr ganz so spektakulär ist, weil natürlich auch Touristen fehlen in Barcelona, in Madrid natürlich. Die Preise hier und da auch teurer sind, später Anstoßzeiten, immer noch Montagsspiele. Jetzt gestern waren es wieder zwei. Also da ist bestimmt die Stimmung noch ein bisschen gedrückt. Aber wenn du jetzt fragst, Thema Super League, da fand ich es auch ganz interessant, was Jogi eben gesagt hat, Thema Investoren. Und in Deutschland da eben sehr schnell viel Kritik, viel Widerstand. Und pauschal erstmal Nein sagen. In Spanien ist da Super League. Jetzt wird auch nicht gleich ad acta gelegt oder gesagt, das wollen wir auf keinen Fall. Also auch da sehen viele diese Monopolstellung von der UEFA, würden da gerne was ändern. Und sehen eben auch, dass Spiele wie der Klassico oder auch, wenn es Bayern gegen Barca ist, wird einfach zehnmal mehr geschaut als so ein Alaves gegen Raio, was irgendwo ja nachvollziehbar ist. Also da ist die Stimmung jetzt generell zu Super League gar nicht so abgelehnt, auch wenn da in den Vorschlägen von Perriss und Co. nicht alles fein war. Aber da ist man jetzt generell nicht so abgeneigt hinsichtlich der Pläne. Und irgendwas soll da ja noch weiterkommen.
Na gut, sowas müsste sich halt auch entwickeln, natürlich. Ich kenne jetzt auch, wenn Osasuna spielt, da kenne ich die Spieler noch nicht so gut. Aber gut, das ist jetzt ein anderes Thema. Ich will jetzt gar nicht die Grundsatzdebatte aufmachen, auch wenn sich die anderen schon mal alle vorbereiten können. Ganz am Schluss möchte ich noch einen ganz kurzen Rumpflug machen, wie sich die Zuschauerzahlen jetzt entwickeln, jetzt wo die Stadion wieder offen sind. Weil sehen wir ja gerade in der Bundesliga, also ich habe jetzt gerade zugeschickt bekommen, wie viele Tickets noch für Dortmund gegen Ingolstadt im DFB-Pokal da sind. Also Leute, wenn ihr noch Bock auf Stadionbesuch habt, gerade kommt man ganz gut ins Westfalen Stadion. Aber das machen wir ganz am Schluss. Dann lassen wir jetzt dann doch über die großen Teams sprechen. Bei Real können wir ja mal beginnen. Drei Punkte Rückstand aktuell. Da ist jetzt noch nichts in den Brunnen gefallen und die Leistungen sind ja auch zwischendurch sehr gut gewesen. Wo liegen jetzt dann trotzdem die Probleme, dass es jetzt dann nur zu einem Unentschieden und einer Niederlage in den letzten beiden Ligaspielen gereicht hat?
Ja, jetzt wettbewerbsübergreifend hat man sogar die letzten drei Partien nicht gewonnen. Also da natürlich die Presse gleich. Das ist schon eine Minikrise bei Real nach einem eigentlich erfolgreichen Saisonstart unter neuem Trainer Carlo Ancelotti ist so ein bisschen das Offensivspektakel zurück. Man stellt mit 22 Toren die beste Offensive in La Liga. Direkt danach übrigens Rayo Vallecano mit 15, auch spektakulär. Also so schlimm ist eigentlich bei Real alles gar nicht. Sie hatten zuletzt ein paar Probleme, das Tor zu finden, dieses Debakel gegen Sheriff Tiraspol. Ja, das kann passieren. 0-0 gegen Real ist jetzt auch nicht so tragisch. Eher jetzt die Niederlage 1-2 bei Aufsteiger Espanol. Die hat schon eher wehgetan, weil die Mannschaft da keine Lösung gefunden hat, irgendwie Tore zu erzielen. Obwohl sie jetzt, es gibt immer mal ein paar Verletzte, aber trotzdem Benzema ist ja trotzdem noch da und der ist nun mal weiter in Überform. Also neun Tore schon in La Liga, sieben Vorlagen. Das ist natürlich der beste Scorer. Aber irgendwie auch mit ihm hat es dagegen den Aufsteiger nicht zum Sieg gereicht. Trotzdem ist da alles noch im grünen Bereich. Also die drei Punkte Rückstand auf Real Sociedad, die sind da. Aber man hat ja auch noch ein Spiel in der Rückhand. Also ist eigentlich alles so, wie erwartet.
Gut, und wie sieht es beim anderen, dritter Verein aus? Bei Atletico, wie ist da die Gemengelage? Gab es ja jetzt mal einen wichtigen Sieg gegen Barcelona. Der ist jetzt allerdings schon eine Weile her. Am 2. Oktober war das.
Genau, weil die jetzt spielfrei eben auch waren am Wochenende. Konnte da Diego Simeone endlich seinen zweiten Ligasieg über Barcelona einfahren? Das war auch hoch verdient so weit. Atletico eben eine spannende Saison, weil die jetzt in einer ganz neuen Rolle sind. Das kennen die gar nicht, die Rolle des Gejagten. Normal sind die ja immer die Jäger. Da haben sie diese Underdog-Rolle auch vergangenen Saison Spieltag für Spieltag eingenommen und am Ende dann verdient die Meisterschaft gewonnen. Jetzt eben da eine neue Rolle. Spannend kann Luis Suárez diese alte Saison noch mal bestätigen, weil letztes Jahr wollte er es wirklich jedem zeigen. Er wurde bei Barcelona vor die Tür gesetzt. Sehr und dankbarer Abschied hat dann einfach noch mal allen gezeigt. Hey, ich hab's immer noch drauf und bin hier einer der besten Mittelstürmer. Der hat jetzt auch schon einige Male getroffen. Und ja, man merkt einfach, bei Atletico wächst weiter was zusammen. Man ist da ja immer noch eine sehr gute Defensive, auch wenn jetzt aktuell Jimenez verletzt war. Das Grießmann-Comeback hat jetzt noch nicht so wirklich funktioniert. João Felix wird jetzt langsam wieder, findet so langsam in die Spur. Also auch Diego Simeone hat hier und da noch einige Baustellen. Aber auch für Atletico sind eigentlich 17 Punkte aus 8 Partien eigentlich voll im grünen Bereich. Besser geht immer, speziell nach der spektakulären Hinrunde vergangenes Jahr. Aber auch Atletico hat da eben Probleme mit den Länderspielen, mit der engen Terminplanung. Und ja, trotzdem ist man da weiter einer der Kandidaten für den Ligatitel, vielleicht mit Real, also die wahrscheinlichsten Kandidaten.
Und was machen wir mit Barca, unserem Sorgenkind der letzten Wochen, der letzten Ausgaben?
Auch Barcelona ist eigentlich alles gar nicht so schlimm, wie es in den letzten Wochen hieß. Die liegen auf Platz 7, Nils. Ja, aber jetzt pass auf. Man hat aktuell 15 Punkte nach 8 Partien, ohne Messi. Vergangenes Jahr mit Messi waren es nach 8 Partien nur 11 Punkte und sogar noch ein paar Tore weniger. Also ja, es ist sportlich überschaubar, aber es ist nicht ganz so tragisch. Man ist ja trotzdem 2 Punkte hinter Real und Atletico. Hat eben auch noch ein Spiel in der Rückhand. Und jetzt eben Hoffnungsträger Anzufati zurück. Er hat jetzt 2 Tore schon gemacht in der Liga. Traumhaftes Ding eigentlich am Wochenende. Da hat man 0-1-früh gegen Valencia zurückgelegen. Am Ende noch verdient 3-1 gewonnen. Auch Memphis Depay fühlt sich wohl beim FC Barcelona. Hat da schon die Liebe der Fans, hat auch schon seine 6-Tor-Beteiligung. Also es geht schon da einiges zusammen. Wenn man da jetzt noch einen Aguero fit bekommt, der hat jetzt sein Debüt gemacht am Wochenende, dann hat man, hat Ronald Koeman schon mehr Optionen vorne. Defensive immer noch so ein bisschen das Problem. Piquet ein bisschen eingerostet. Eric Garcia hat hier und da auch mal seine Fehlerchen, seinen Platzverweis auch in der Nationalmannschaften jetzt eben noch Araujo verletzt. Aber auch da ist alles gar nicht so tragisch. Ronald Koeman hat da eben auch die Erwartung ein bisschen runtergeschraubt und gemeint, man kann in der Champions League nicht allzu viel erwarten. Mit der Mannschaft ist es nun mal schwierig. Also man hat den Ligatitel jetzt noch nicht komplett abgeschrieben, aber die Fans wissen da, glaube ich, dass man jetzt keine Wunderdinge erwarten kann. Aber ja, aktuell ist die Tabelle einfach noch ein bisschen verwässert durch das, dass die Top-Teams jeweils ein Spiel weniger haben. Und so Teams wie Osasuna, Nuayu, Valle Cano, so viel Spaß, die aktuell auch machen, keine Frage. Die haben eben jetzt auch noch in ihrem bisherigen Spielplan noch keine Top-Teams wirklich gehabt. Also das kommt jetzt in den nächsten Wochen erst. Und wenn sie da auch wirklich gegen Real, Atletico, Barca zumindest vier Pünktchen holen, dann auf jeden Fall haben sie ihren Topsaisonstart bestätigt. Aber so, das wird sich schon alles einpendeln. Und am Ende Real, Atletico, Barca und speziell auch Sevilla werden da weiter oben stehen.
Und bist da jetzt nur du so entspannt? Oder spiegelt das auch die Stimmung vor Ort wieder? Denn du hast ja jetzt so nonchalant erwähnt. In der Champions League läuft es gerade nicht so gut. Ja, das kann man so sagen. Also wir erinnern uns an das 0 zu 3 gegen die Bayern. Es folgte ein 0 zu 3 bei Benfica. Aktuell, logischerweise, Barca damit mit Nullpunktentabellen. Letzter in dieser Gruppe heißt jetzt nicht, dass die sich nicht für die K.o.-Runde qualifizieren. Heißt aber, die müssen jetzt auf jeden Fall gewinnen. Also da ist jetzt ordentlich Druck auf dem Kessel.
Ja, Champions League natürlich nochmal was anderes nach diesen auch zwei eigentlich katastrophalen oder Blamagen schon fast gegen Bayern und Benfica. Da im Endeffekt mein nonchalant, es kommt vielleicht auch daher, dass Ronald Koeman eigentlich gar nicht so sehr wackelt, wie es vielleicht in Medien immer dargestellt wird. Also er hat eben die Erwartungshaltung schon runtergeschraubt. Im Endeffekt hat Präsident Laporta jetzt auch keinen Plan B gehabt, weil er kein anderer Trainer vielleicht verfügbar war oder weil er nicht Koeman noch weiter zahlen wollte und beurlauben wollte. Deswegen wird das irgendwie so weitergehen. Und dadurch, dass jetzt auch in Dembele bald zurückkehrt und dann ist auch bald Araujo wieder dabei, hat da die Mannschaft zumindest wieder ein bisschen mehr Personalauswahl. Petri, wenn der wieder fit ist, Fati sowieso, wenn der bei den 100 Prozent ist. Aber ja, der Druck ist natürlich jetzt da gegen Kiew. Aber ich sag mal so, dadurch, dass man die Bayern in der Gruppe hat, kann man vielleicht auch auf Schützenhilfe hoffen. Also dass Bayern dann ebenso auch Kiew und Benfica abschießt und dass man so dann einfach noch Platz zwei in Anführungszeichen locker erreichen kann. Champions League-Gruppenphase ist ja, ja, man hat zweimal verloren, aber so wirklich, man kann ja auch zwei, drei Spiele in der Gruppenphase verlieren und qualifiziert sich dann trotzdem noch mit neun Punkten. Also real wurde in dieser verrückten Gruppe letztes Jahr gegen Gladbach, Schachtier und Inter wurde noch irgendwie erster am letzten Spieltag, obwohl die auch gegen Schachtier beides verloren haben und gegen Gladbach unentschieden. Also noch ist da lange nicht alles verloren, aber klar, Druck ist da.
Na gut, das ist ja auch mal ganz schön zu sehen, dass aus der Ferne die Feuer dann doch gar nicht so lodernd brennen, wie man das vielleicht gedacht hätte. Als wir in der letzten Ausgabe mit Fabian Pakulat darüber gesprochen haben, welche Teams man sich mal angucken sollte, hat der Valencia, Rayo Vallecano und San Sebastian empfohlen. Wen würdest du denn jetzt mal vorliegend auf dem Stand ein paar Spiele später empfehlen?
Ja, Valencia hatte einen ziemlich guten Saisonstart, aber jetzt aus den letzten fünf Partien auch nur zwei Pünktchen geholt. Rayo ist ein sehr guter Tipp, speziell bei Heimspielen. Die haben alle ihre vier gewonnen. Ich war einmal dabei, das sind Festspiele da. Wenn da noch mal Chaos trifft, dann exkludiert das Campo de Vallecas auf jeden Fall. Real Sociedad auch sehr gut drauf als Tabellenführer natürlich. Da ist es immer spannend. Die haben auch sehr viele Ausfälle. Also Iyara Mendy kennt man natürlich. David Silva hat noch nicht gespielt dieses Jahr. Carlos Fernandez, der Mittelstürmer. Jetzt war sogar Oya Sabal am Wochenende, hat gefehlt. Trotzdem hat sie irgendwie zu einem 1-0-Sieg gereicht. Die hatten dann in ihrem Heimspiel auch noch endlich die Copa del Rey, den Titel, präsentieren können. Also da ist schon immer spannend, wie da Alguacil Spiel für Spiel eine neue L findet, noch einen Plan C findet und es trotzdem zum Erfolg reicht. Und wenn ich noch ein drittes Team nennen müsste, Valencia nicht, würde ich vielleicht sagen Sevilla, weil die einfach auch, oder weil da einfach auch jetzt seit drei Jahren was sehr Gutes zusammenwächst, eine sehr gute Defensive, die haben erst drei Gegentore kassiert in der Liga. Da hat Gylen Lopetegui, leistet ganze Arbeit offensiv, meist überschaubar, das ist dann meistens doch nur so ein abgeklärter, sehr erfahrener 1-0-Sieg. Aber irgendwie ist Sevilla, spielt dann einen sehr professionellen, erfahrenen Fußball, wo andere Mannschaften noch nicht so wirklich ein Mittel gefunden haben, auch wenn die auch schon mal gestolpert sind.
Okay, ich sehe schon, da gibt es so einiges, was man sich dann doch angucken kann. Ich empfehle mal vielleicht den 27. Oktober, da spielt Rayo Vallecano zu Hause gegen Barca. Nach allem, was du gesagt hast, ist das eins dieser Spiele. Das könnte man sich dann doch mal vielleicht zumindest auf einem Bildschirm mit angucken. Dann ganz schnelle Fragerunde. Wir müssen nicht in die Diskussion gehen, aber was mich interessiert, Nies, du darfst dann beginnen. Wie ist denn die Situation mit den Zuschauern? Kommen die denn jetzt schon zurück, wenn sie dürfen?
Sie dürfen, 100 Prozent sind wieder erlaubt. Aber man spürt in Spanien noch sehr ein Respekt, ein bisschen Angst vor Corona, vor den Ansammlungen auf Toiletten beim Einlass, also jetzt im Camp Nou waren es 47.000 von 99.000. Jetzt bei Real Sociedad waren es 31.000 von 39.000. Also es wächst nach und nach, aber es ist nicht so, dass durch die Euphorie jetzt gleich die Stadien bei 100 Prozent gefüllt sind, eben auch durch späte Zeiten, hohe Preise, wenig Tourismus.
Gut, dann machen wir das jetzt genau in der umgedrehten Reihenfolge, wie wir die Ligen besprochen haben. Jetzt müsst ihr alle ganz schnell nachdenken. Jogi ist dann als nächstes dran. Wie ist denn die Situation gerade mit der Zuschauerauslastung in der Premier League?
Also, wenn ich ehrlich bin, habe ich mich damit jetzt noch nicht umgekehrt beschäftigt im Sinne von, dass ich irgendwas gesehen hätte, dass ein Stadion leer geblieben wäre. Also, ich glaube, der Engländer ist da komplett spaßbefreit. Er nimmt das einfach an und ist froh, wieder da zu sein. Und irgendwie sogar habe ich das Gefühl, noch frenetischer als davor, weil man es irgendwie zu schätzen war. Also, mir wäre jetzt nicht bewusst, dass irgendwo ein Stadion leer geblieben wäre oder irgendwo ein Sitz leer geblieben wäre, ganz im Gegenteil.
Alexi, wie ist die Situation in der Ligue 1?
Ja, ein bisschen wie in England. Man hat wieder 100 Prozent Auslastung seit Beginn der Saison. Und wie ich vorher schon erwähnt, sind bei großen Vereinen wie Marseille, wie Paris Saint-Germain, das Stadion immer voll. Es war in Marseille am Sonntag in Anführungszeichen nur gegen Lorient. So gut die Ausverkauf mit 63.000 Zuschauern. Und das wird auch ausverkauft komplett sein natürlich am Sonntag gegen Paris. Und das ist auch eigentlich nur in Monaco nicht voll, aber das war noch nie voll.
Und wie ist es in der Serie A, Christian?
Ja, Italien war am vorsichtigsten, was die Regierungsvorgaben betrifft. Also erst jetzt, am vergangenen Wochenende durften zum ersten Mal 75 Prozent rein. Davor waren es bis jetzt 50 Prozent. Die Clubs machen zwar schon lange Druck und wollen endlich auf diese 100 auch wieder kommen. Womöglich mal schauen, vielleicht könnte das dann auch irgendwann im November so sein. Aber da war schon noch ein bisschen eine Bremse drin, was auch ein Fakt war, gewisse Fan-Gruppen, gewisse Kurven haben gegen die Corona-Maßnahmen auch, fanden das alles andere als gut, sind teilweise ferngeblieben. Aber es ist jetzt, man merkt schon, sehr viel Euphorie. Gerade wenn du dir die Mainländer-Fereine anschaust bei mir, dann ist San Siro richtig gut voll, als so was möglich war. Juve auch, Rom zum Beispiel. Ganz interessant, viele Clubs, dadurch, dass ja bisher nur 50 Prozent erlaubt waren, hatten gar keinen richtigen Abo-Verkauf, weil mit 50 Prozent. Und jetzt geht es so langsam los. Und die Roma hat, glaube ich, innerhalb von wenigen Tagen all die 18.000 aus der Kurva Sud sozusagen einen Mann gebracht. Also es ist schon viel Lust auf Fußball da. Und die Hoffnung, sorry, nochmal bei den Vereinen, ist eben, dass man auch bald auf die 100 Prozent kommen darf.
Gut, dann danke ich euch allen sehr. Deine Stimme hat jetzt Feierabend, zumindest kurzzeitig. Christian, ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich bei Christian Bernhard, bei Nies Kern, bei Alexis Menuge und bei Jogi Hebel. Danke euch, Viren, das hat große Freude gemacht. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei wart im Rasenfunk. Dann bleibt mir an dieser Stelle nur noch der Hinweis, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, der Rasenfunk ist werbesponsoren und paywallfrei. Wir finanzieren uns allein über eure freiwillige finanzielle Unterstützung. Wie ihr das tun könnt, erfahrt ihr auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Und nicht nur wir profitieren davon, sondern auch unsere Gäste, die daraus ein kleines Honorar bekommen. Also, bitte unterstützt uns. Ganz herzlichen Dank an alle, die das schon bis hierhin getan haben. Wir hören uns wieder in einem unserer zahlreichen Formate. Bis dahin, bleibt gesund, passt auf euch auf. Bis bald mal wieder hier im Rasenfunk.